welcome to you heard with perd i'm perd
hapley
the story of our guest today is that
they are from the department of parks
and recreation
ben wyatt and tom haverford what up perd
big fan
me too perd what up the thing about this
first question is
i'd like to ask you about the harvest
festival perd it's gonna be amazing
carnival rides games sweden is even
building
a plus-sized roller coaster for some of
pawnee's obese thrill-seekers
you must be this wide to ride wow that's
gonna be a pretty big roller coaster
yep man did you buy anything for
yourself today
yeah i got this pack of socks plain
white socks that's not a treat
donna get me away from him maybe this is
our version of treat yourself day and he
needs to do his version what are you
talking about
why if you could blow big money on one
thing not sock money
what would it be
oh my god oh my god oh my god this is a
whole new level of nerd
you're right this is ridiculous what am
i doing wait no no no no no i mean that
in a good way ben
listen to me you're part of the treat
yourself team now okay
if that costume somehow makes you happy
you're gonna buy it
and you're gonna wear it out of the
store okay you're gonna treat yourself
yeah you know what i'm gonna do that i'm
gonna
i'm gonna treat myself thanks you guys
thank you
i really needed this
i gotta treat myself
uh oh batman's crying
the internet's not working ben we need
your help
guys i've told you how to do it you just
unplug the router and then you plug it
back in again
i guess i'll do it
still not working well give it a minute
good
okay it's working
good morning ben oh sorry sorry did they
scare you
no i just wanted to remind you of the
art show that's happening tonight
at the community center great well that
sounds cool that sounds like uh
something that'll be a big success you
know
i mean like everything that you uh that
you put your your
your paws on your fingers so i have some
ideas for the health initiative oh okay
how about i swing by later and and we'll
just you know
go over everything or we could go out
after work
you know go to jj's or something grab a
bite um i don't i don't think i can
but why don't we just talk about it
later in this building
okay all right but uh you're great and
you have great ideas
and um
uh bye how'd it go well
there were some sticky moments let's go
to the videotape
ah look who hasn't had gay thoughts
who are you okay yeah i'm fine i'm fine
i mean you know sometimes i feel like i
might need glasses
is there a bird in here i swear i keep
seeing a bird
in the studio maybe that's kind of the
same he was fine until bird started
asking about the boy mayor's stuff
what's wrong with you you look psychotic
i was 18 when i was elected mayor okay
so excuse me for that
cindy eckert had just turned me down for
senior prom do you know how that feels i
should call her
i should i no i shouldn't and i'm not
going to and i'm proud of myself for
that
and then he talked about feeling up
cindy eckert for the first time for
about five minutes
and then the show ended as did our
careers and probably harvest fest
boom sadness that's the one
if i thought you were serious i'd be
offended bird but i know that we're
buddies
i know you wouldn't do that to me but no
this is a birthmark perd
okay this is the little scar i got when
i was nine and i fell off my bike so no
i'm not perfect i can't look away it's
um
it's amazing okay wait no here's the
best part okay
uh that's all the time we have here on
you heard
i'm heard happily channel four more like
turd crapley
[Applause]
i had no right to disparage your town
well i owe you guys an apology
too i uh had a little bad publicity
lately and
frankly it's still really easy to score
points by bashing wyatt
can't you just give ben a key to the
city
here now in your office where no one
will know your shame
sorry babe no worries i love you
uh you know if people found out i gave
wyatt the key to this idiot
i would never get reelected so no
what are you doing there wyatt i'm
feeding your eagle
he's starving it's it's bronze babe
why the eagle we should go yeah
chief tremble nice to see you hi hey
nope wyatt
it's been a long time hey captain or
captain uh oh captain my captain
from dead poet society you getting weird
already nope
i'm good pawnee's police chief is
retiring and i'm trying to get his
endorsement before he goes
i'm really nervous because i need this
for my campaign
and ben is really nervous because he's
afraid of cops i'm not afraid
of cops i have no reason to be i never
break any laws ever
because i'm deathly afraid of cops
look nope i've always liked you but the
new ports run this town and frankly
they've donated a lot of money to the
department
mo money no problems that's what i
always say how about
mo money more protected kevlar vests
that save lives i i
sometimes i say that too i understand
you need to think about it but if you
were gonna make a decision
guys are throwing me a little retirement
thing tonight at o'flynnigan's
there's gonna be beer so i want you to
swing by i'll give you an answer
weirdo can come too all right let's go
oh hey
uh may i say the boys in blue stop
our heroes obviously some more than
others
oh boy here comes
9 11. and we're walking okay
go ahead
[Music]
oh go ahead
oh hey dave go ahead
[Applause]
this place is outstanding great call
leslie knope
look even ben's dancing well i am very
glad you came back up here
oh yeah me too yeah so you got a deal
well let me mull everything over and
then we can reconnect and hash things
out
it might get rough but that can be fun
ben can handle it yep
i can okay great it was a pleasure oh
mm-hmm
what is wrong with you today did they
cancel game of thrones nothing is wrong
just do your job
and they would never cancel game of
thrones it's a crossover hit
it's not just for fantasy enthusiasts
they're telling human stories in a
fantasy world
fill out the forms please thank you
there's one more thing i want to try
i got you something in london a
traditional barrister's wig
oh wear it for me yeah
all right
what's up no not sexy failed experiment
take it off okay just take it off okay
now uh calculator
oh you like that one huh
we do not get a lot of humor here and
when we do it's wonderful
oh ted come in here say it to ted when
he comes in
so this guy ben wyatt we're looking him
up on alta vista
he's from some hicktown partridge
minnesota
and when he's 18 he's elected
mayor
[Music]
that's funny that's funny he's 18
becomes the mayor
and then blows the whole budget on an
ice skating rink
city goes bankrupt no you're out of
there
what'd you call it again yeah what was
it called
say it ice town
[Laughter]
i was a kid and when you you
you you end up getting out there and uh
and there's uh i really wish you guys
could see this guy right now he is
dronched in sweat
there's also gonna be ponies at the
harvest festival all right let's take a
caller from douche nation
all right talk to me caller what's up
guys just douching over here in eagleton
sweet seems like 18 is pretty young for
a mayor
what were you like 12. the funny um
when i guess
the fortunate um can we just
sort of game over man
game over talking about the highway to
the calzone zone you know
if you want to ask him questions let's
go for it huh let's ask any question
about his past or present just get it
over with ben let's get up here
yeah yeah come on we'll just ask him a
bunch of questions and then we'll get
everything cleared and out of the way
sound good yeah great good uh let's take
some calls
joan why don't you okay uh caller are
you there
yeah how can you justify raising taxes
for something that will hurt the town
you